(Music)
(Singing) It was a teenage wedding
and the old folks wished them well.
You could see that Pierre
did truly love the mademoiselle.
Oh,
and now the young monsieur and madame
have rung the chapel bell.
C'est la vie, say the old folks,
it goes to show you never can tell.
No, no.
They furnished off an apartment
with a two-room Roebuck sale.
The coolerator was crammed
with TV dinners and ginger ale.
Oh,
but when Pierre found work,
the little money comin' worked out well .
C'est la vie, say the old folks,
it goes to show you never can tell.
You never can tell.
They bought a souped-up jitney,
was a cherry red '53.
They drove it down to New Orleans
to celebrate their anniversary.
Oh,
it was there where Pierre
was wedded to the lovely mademoiselle.
C'est la vie, say the old folks,
it goes to show you never can tell.
No, no,
you never can tell.
You never can tell.
No, no,
you never can tell.
(Applause and cheers)
Thank you.
I recently had the tremendous opportunity
of searching for gold
in the vast mine of songs
released by Chess Records,
a Chicago-based label that was really
very active in the '50s and '60s in the US
and that music spread all over the world.
And the songs that I'm singing tonight
are from an album that I just put out
called, "Playing Chess,"
that pays homage to those songs.
And these guys were really the innovators
of rock 'n' roll and soul and R&B
as we now know it.
(Applause)
(Music)
(Singing) Over the mountain,
across the sea,
there's a girl waiting,
she's waiting for ...
me.
(Music)
Over the river,
beyond every cloud,
she's passed the wind blowin' loud.
Over the mountain,
a girl waits for me.
(Music)
Tell the sands,
every blade of grass,
please tell the wind to let my love pass.
Over the mountain,
a girl waits for me.
Tell the moon up --
up in the sky.
Tell all the birds that fly on by
that over and over the mountain ...
my love waits for me.
Oh,
into each dark, starry night,
oh, what a mystery
that's sealed so tight.
Over the mountain,
a girl waits for me.
Tell the moon up --
up in the sky.
Tell the birds that fly by
that over and over the mountain
my love waits for me.
Into each dark and starry night,
oh, what a mystery
that's sealed so tight.
Over the mountains,
a girl waits for me.
She waits for me.
Oh, she waits for me.
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know.
Oh,
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know,
oh oh, oh oh.
(Applause and cheers)